next two speakers are MIT physics
professor so put your seat belts on our
first speaker is Professor Aaron
Bernstein who was already mentioned
briefly by Jonathan in the first session
Aaron teaches particle physics and has
been one of the people who were had
direct association with the people who
had worked on the Manhattan Project like
Phil Morrison he's also the national
board member of the Council for livable
world and has taught many courses at MIT
on nuclear weapons and nuclear
proliferation so we are lucky to have
Aaron and he's going to talk about the
dangers arising from the modernization
of the u.s. arsenal in particular the
b61 12 modernization which is a
so-called tactical nuclear weapon
meaning battlefield and they want to
make it very accurate now with all the
guidance systems that we can put in and
and the talk of usable nuclear weapon is
again coming back this is from james
Cartwright who is supposed to be a good
guy that's general but and then he's
also going to talk about a thousand
cruise missiles that we are also putting
in as part of the modernization so if we
are ready with that you'll get to be
like a rock star in use this microphone
a little out might work okay so now I'm
a rock
son this is the first time in my life
I've been a rock star let me tell you so
I'm honored and and okay look I want to
make a few comments the first is I want
to welcome people and I'm glad to see
all the younger people and students and
anyone who wants any one of you students
who want to follow up after this the
doors are open my doors are open so
that's number one number two I want to
make the general comment that we often
fall into the trap that we talked about
the numbers of nuclear weapons and what
I want to talk about is their qualities
in particular the way they're basing
modes and their alert status I don't
need to emphasize any more about the
alert status because Elizabeth has
definitely touched that that's a major
point so I want to move on to their
characteristics and in particular their
accuracy okay and modernization is a
word that is misused in in the sense
that might be good keep talking okay the
point is that when we make the missiles
more accurate they become more likely to
be perceived as a first strike weapon so
the difference between hair-trigger
alert and the potential use of these
weapons as a first strike weapon is
something wrong with the sound
max healthy we can always trust
technology can never go wrong all right
let's see if we can get this to not play
the slides automatically oh it's playing
it automatically okay okay fine ah ok
thank you think we've solved my issue as
well okay you can hear me well i'm no
longer rock star back to my normal
academic presentation beware of MIT
physics professors because it's like
drinking from a fire okay so here goes
okay I'll try not to do that I want to
start with the an old issue which came
up during the 80s and intrigued me
namely why was the Soviet Union the
Russians so afraid of Star Wars which
they called space strike weapons they
were first afraid because these intense
lasers promoted by edward teller at all
would shine down tremendous death rays
on the earth you know like science
fiction but the the Soviet scientists
understood this this was not to be
technically not to be and but the
Russians were still afraid and they were
afraid and I was thinking about this and
I actually took a semester off to think
about this particular issue in the
mid-80s and the conclusion i came to at
that point was they were afraid of all a
high-tech weaponry all the developments
in surveillance and command and control
that was the issue they could not match
it and they didn't want to match it it's
very expensive we were pouring tons of
money into it and technically they
couldn't do it they will week
on the computer aspects the surveillance
aspects etc okay and this was
fascinating and this if you fast-forward
to today because it's important today
this is exactly why they're still afraid
and the rubric that this goes under is
modernization okay and the thing I want
to convey to you is mutual vulnerability
when their systems don't work well if
they fire out of fear or misuse of the
system erroneous use a false alarm in
other words they fire we're all dead
it's a mutual suicide pact i won't i
won't go into the tremendous talk that I
Rahel phone gave us but you heard it so
I've covered this so basically the
National Labs the US National Labs were
given the task of maintaining the
weapons without testing and this has
gone on for more than 20 years and this
is a quite a success story because in in
doing this the US National Labs have
understood the physical basis of the
weapons much better than they ever
understood during the era of testing
okay so they have a much more rigorous
understanding through examination of the
components and through testing of the
components but slipping in is the word
modernization which means that you
upgrade the capabilities of the weapons
and the major upgrade is the accuracy
and i'm going to show you three slides
five minutes okay three slides
on the modernization which i got from
Ted postal so first of all what you have
here is an increase in first of all the
basic physics is the following that the
destructive power is the yield over the
error how accurately can you hit that's
called the CP circular error probable
okay but it's the error and it's the
square so if you improve the weapon
improve you increase the yield ten
percent that's one thing if you decrease
the circular error by five percent you
get the same ten percent increase in the
lethality of that weapon now what you
have here is a slide that Ted postal
made where you take the size of the
error this is about where we think it is
now for our submarine-based missiles
which are our most devastating first
strike missile now it isn't like it was
in the early cold that Cold War days
when when these missiles had less
accuracy but now they have the greatest
accuracy and then they have this new
fusing mechanism which increases the
problem to kill probability from roughly
fifty percent to the order of
eighty-five ninety percent ok so this
the lethality the kill probability is
almost a hundred percent with the new
fusing and this is for a very hardened
silo the Russians claim their silos are
a factor of five less hardened by the
way for the cognoscenti
this is how it works is there's a whole
area i'm not going to press this too
much but with conventional fusing you
have a certain range of possible errors
when you hit the target the target is
here the target is presumably a Russian
missile silo and now with the advanced
fusing see this is the volume in which
you would make a destructive hit and
with the advanced fusing it's all almost
all the hits are in that volume okay so
you're getting close to one hundred
percent destructive capability with the
new fusing and this is a dramatic
example I couldn't resist showing this
this shows the crater size from from the
larger explosive power there are two
possible explosive powers in these
submarine-launched missiles this is the
more explosive one and this shows the
crater and this shows a building the
size of the US Capitol so you get the
scale okay so these are enormous craters
that can be created so you get a feeling
for the destructive potential of one
upgraded missile so Lizbeth has
discussed the possibility of an
accidental nuclear war I won't stress
this at all I just want to show we have
other plans to upgrade missiles this is
a very controversial missile it's the
b12 the b-1b 61 excuse me missile model
12 the model 12 is critical with these
tail fins and higher accuracy okay
here's the message we live in a mad mad
you know remember mutual assured
destruction but mad in
normal meaning of that word look it up
in Webster okay and it's mad and we live
in a mutually dangerous world if they
fire will fire and vice versa and we're
mutually vulnerable and when their
radars are not up to snuff their early
warning and they aren't up to snuff we
are in greater danger and Lizabeth
talked about the warning time u.s.
presidents have 15 minutes warning time
Russian presidents probably have three
minutes so keep that in mind and we are
vulnerable so thank you